next question today is hey david trump
is talking about not knowing the results
of this election for days weeks or
months
when do you think we will know who won
the 2020 election
so about um three weeks ago i would have
said to you
it could be seven days after november
3rd so like by november 10th we will
know the results
with every passing day i actually think
we will probably know the results
not much later than november 4th i think
the day after the election
i don't believe this is going to be
close enough
that we will need a full week to know
the results now
if and whether donald trump concedes if
he loses
that's a very different question but i
am increasingly
when you look at there are basically the
issue is absentee ballots
in a normal election according to the
brookings institute about
30 of the ballots that are cast would be
expected to be mailed in
it is now expected to be more than half
and there are basically
three scenarios for when states can
count absentee ballots
states can just start counting as as
they come in before election day meaning
they're already counting mail-in ballots
in some states
there are states where the absentee
ballots can start to be counted
uh at the in the morning before the
polls close
even if they have been mailed in so
november third in the morning people
start voting in person and they start
opening and counting absentee ballots
and then the third scenario is only when
the polls
close can you start counting absentee
ballots
the vast majority of states
that matter are not in that last
category and i
it escapes me now but there are two
states
i i want to say pennsylvania and one
other
of the states that are in the last
category where the results may take a
while to have
from the absentee ballots there are very
few that have a shot at making a
difference in the results now
pennsylvania certainly is one of them
and the reason why i am
increasingly thinking it's not going to
take a week to know the results
is that pennsylvania is going more and
more in the direction of joe biden this
week
in fact we had polls saying joe biden is
up eight
in pennsylvania or even more and that is
the one
there may be one other that is one of
the few states that could be a deciding
state
that has this we don't start counting
until the polls close sort of uh
scenario and i
i may even be misremembering that bottom
line
the the gist is i think
the election results being delayed will
have
more to do with whether donald trump
successfully uses lawyers and courts
to slow down or stop the counting of
absentee ballots
and or to get ballots dismissed which he
successfully did
in iowa this week or last week i think
it will have more to do with that
than the actual time it will take to
count the ballots i think that if the
ballots are allowed to be counted
um normally without interference
that this is going to be an election
where we know the results on november
4th now that could be like midnight
as november 5th is starting i think the
real chance for a delay
would be donald trump creating one
through using lawyers courts lawsuits
and the like
let's hope it doesn't happen let's hope
it is so
a blowout for joe biden which depends on
us
that it doesn't even matter that even on
election night
it becomes clear that joe biden won it
could happen
it could happen the next few weeks will
determine ultimately what does happen
if you've been watching the show you've
probably heard me talk about how much i
love
my helix mattress well i was really
excited to hear that helix has launched
a new company called
all form which makes premium
customizable sofas and chairs
with the same level of quality and
comfort
that i expect from these guys and all
form is one of our sponsors today
they're giving you twenty percent off at
allforum.com
pacman they actually sent me a couch
which i
put in my living room at home it's now
my favorite piece of furniture in the
house
it took me just minutes to set it up
it's solidly built
it's huge it's roomy it has a modern
minimalist design which i love but it's
also
very comfortable fabric is soft clearly
very high quality
it has become the focal point of my
living room
their prices are very reasonable and
when you get a new sofa or
chair you get 100 days to decide if you
want to keep it and the best part is
everything comes with a lifetime
warranty
stop buying poorly made furniture go to
customize
your own all form sofa or chair right
now
and get 20 off your entire order when
you get there
by going to all form dot com slash
pacman
i've also put the link right underneath
this video